we have a david pakman show subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT some
really good discussions happening there
were approaching about 6,000 of our
viewers and listeners who are subscribed
to our subreddit let's go through some
of the interesting comments and posts on
our subreddit that i spotted this
morning including a very interesting
article pointing out that now as a
result of Jared Kushner losing his
top-secret security clearance that the
chief calligrapher of the White House
now has a higher clearance than Jared
Kushner which is interesting yet listen
what this is very funny but the truth is
that Jared Kushner's presence in the
administration has been concerning and
out of place for a very long time and I
feel like being demoted below the
calligrapher in terms of your security
clearance is just sort of adding insult
to injury I think it's more insightful
that the White House has a chief oh yeah
I guess they have multiple then well is
do you think that that's for those like
executive orders that Trump signs like
they're written in nice calligraphy huh
I assume that those were printed just in
like a calligraphy font from a computer
but maybe they actually have someone
writing those he ruins it with his
cardiogram signature his very strange
signature yeah okay also from the david
pakman show subreddit officials from
several states are offering delta
airlines a new home amid the nra
blowback we mentioned this yesterday and
i think it was you pat who mentioned
something like listen there's a risk to
going after delta if you're the state of
georgia as they've done because delta
can always move to another state and i
mentioned well they could but it's you
know delta has been committed to atlanta
as its primary hub as a world hub for a
very long time it would be difficult and
it would but there is no shortage of
states that have come out of the
woodwork who were saying hey we'd love
to have delta in our state even with
their elimination of a discount for NRA
members i think everyone's just flexing
their muscles here republicans aren't
gonna take away their tax credits you
don't think so Delta's not gonna move
probably not will see we will see a
discussion you can participate in if you
have an opinion about it also from the
david pakman show subreddit defense
secretary james madison did keeping
transgender troops in the military
according to a new report on military
comm yeah
I'm not surprised and I'm no like big
cheerleader of Jim mattis but you could
sort of tell from the beginning of
trumps a attempt to eliminate all
transgender servicemembers from the
branches of the American military you
kind of got the feeling that mattis
wasn't on board first the Department of
Defense had something like listen
mattis's like on vacation he wasn't
informed of this then that is sort of
wants to wait and see and get a report
and now Matt essentially think we should
keep transgender troops this is not a
surprise even though Trump said that he
consulted with his generals before
making that decision apparently not one
of them yeah mattis was out of town that
day literally speaking he was he was
actually not in town the day Trump
tweeted that transgender servicemembers
we're gonna be kicked out this is how
politics is being done these days folks
I'm not joking around and lastly from
the David Pakman show subreddit what do
you all do to detox from American
politics sometimes it gets so depressing
and so many piles of manure around I
just need to take a break from it what
do you all do the redditor is asking
yeah I you know what I do is I try to
not pay attention to politics over the
weekend like Sunday evening I'll sit
down and start looking at what happened
and putting together my thoughts for
what I want to cover on Monday but
basically from the time we're done with
the Friday show until Sunday evening I
barely pay attention to politics and
it's very common that I'll like get
together with a friend for brunch on
Sunday morning and they'll mention
something and I'll have absolutely no
idea because it happened Friday night or
Saturday during the during the day I
think that the plan brakes are sort of
good because it does get very toxic
especially in the era of Trump yeah you
got a detox in some way yeah be it yoga
or a hot tub something like that yes
absolutely well listen more about that
on the bonus show Pat will tell us all
about how he's what's going on in hot
tubs with him all right join us on our
subreddit david pakman.com slash reddit
respectful political discussion we have
moderators making sure that people don't
get out of hand
join I'm on there Pat is on there are
very very exciting stuff